bienvenido a la presentación del teorema
de pitágoras seguramente has escuchado
hablar de este teorema antes pero una
cosa curiosa es que hasta donde yo sé es
el único teorema matemático que tiene el
nombre de un fundador de religión si
resulta que pitágoras tenía su religión
y creo que tenía que ver con números
pero bueno yo no soy historiador mejor
dejémosle eso a los historiadores y
vamos a hacer un poco de matemáticas
vale todo empieza con un triángulo
y este triángulo va a cumplir algo
especial no es un triángulo cualquiera
este triángulo va a cumplir que algunos
de sus ángulos es de 90 grados es decir
es un ángulo recto puedes pensar o
reflexionar por tu cuenta si si en un
triángulo puede haber más de un ángulo
recto pero bueno ahorita nada más vamos
a pensar que tiene un ángulo recto vale
y lo vamos a marcar así con una cajita
cuadrada en vez del símbolo tradicional
de ángulo curvo bueno el teorema de
pitágoras es un teorema acerca de estos
triángulos de los triángulos con esta
propiedad especial y básicamente nos
dice que si conocemos dos de los lados
entonces podemos determinar el tercero y
nos da una fórmula para hacerlo pero
bueno antes de decir el teorema de
pitágoras déjame darte una definición
adicional como ya te dije este ángulo de
90 grados se llama el ángulo recto y el
lado que es opuesto al ángulo recto se
conoce como hipotenusa vale entonces
esta de acá va a ser la hipotenusa
y por qué no usa vaya esta es una
palabra bien complicada verdad consignó
lo veo como que hasta se puede espantar
y dice hipo hasta puede pensar en
hipopótamos y así o que te puede dar
hipo bueno es espantosa la palabra pero
en realidad es una cosa bien bonita
porque la hipotenusa tiene mucho que ver
con el teorema de pitágoras vale bueno
entonces ahora si el teorema de
pitágoras dice lo siguiente vamos a
llamar a la hipotenusa a la longitud de
la hipotenusa se vale observa que ese es
la longitud más larga de los lados del
triángulo este de aquí es el lado más
largo bueno entonces si la longitud de
la hipotenusa se llama ce y las
longitudes de los otros dos lados se
llaman a y ve lo que dice el teorema de
pitágoras es que al cuadrado más b al
cuadrado es igual a c al cuadrado y
bueno estoy aquí parece una igualdad muy
sencilla muy simple pero en realidad es
súper poderosa es de las igualdades más
poderosas en matemáticas tiene que ver
con geometría euclidiana con
econometría un poco con vectores entre
otras cosas después veremos más
aplicaciones pero bueno ahorita tenemos
nuestra fórmula y la vamos a poner a
prueba o más bien yo diría vamos a
resolver algunos problemas utilizando la
quizás después en otros vídeos veamos
una demostración de esta fórmula vale
una prueba pero bueno ahorita vamos a
algunos ejemplos déjame cambiar de color
para que no sean tan monótonas las cosas
y bueno imaginemos que tenemos un
triángulo o así tenemos un triángulo
más o menos de esta forma y vamos a
pensar que es un triángulo rectángulo
con el ángulo recto aquí aquí y que este
lado mide 3 y este lado mide 4 y
queremos determinar la longitud de este
lado de acá bueno la idea es utilizar el
teorema de pitágoras y lo primero que yo
hago para utilizar el teorema de
pitágoras es determinar quién es la
hipotenusa la hipotenusa es el lado que
es opuesto al ángulo recto opuesto al
ángulo recto entonces en este caso sería
estar acá verdad estoy acá sería c en el
teorema de pitágoras entonces lo que nos
dice esta fórmula es que sea al cuadrado
o bueno 3 al cuadrado + +
más hasta 4 al cuadrado es igual a c al
cuadrado
al cuadrado vale la suma de los
cuadrados de los otros dos lados es
igual al cuadrado de la hipotenusa a
veces estos lados se les llaman catetos
pero ya exponer demasiados nombres bueno
entonces tenemos esta igualdad de acá y
de aquí podemos desarrollar este 3 al
cuadrado nos quedan 9 más 4 al cuadrado
que es 16 es igual a c al cuadrado de
esta forma tenemos que 25 es igual a c
al cuadrado y ahora podemos obtenerse
sacando raíz de ambos lados se puede ser
más o menos 5 pero como se es una
longitud entonces se tiene que ser
positivo y por lo tanto c es igual a 5
vale entonces justo el teorema de
pitágoras sirvió para obtener el tercer
lado conociendo la medida de los otros
dos bueno vamos a hacer otro otro
ejemplo en el cual el lado que
desconocemos no es la hipotenusa sino
uno de los catetos o de los otros dos
lados vale déjame tomar el color naranja
y voy a dibujar otro triángulo por acá
entonces ahora vamos a poner un
triángulo más o menos así más o menos
así y algo así vale y pensemos que el
ángulo recto está de este lado que este
lado mide 6 que este lado mide 12 y lo
que queremos hacer es determinar la
medida del lado de acá aquí hay que
tener un poco de cuidado otra vez
el primer paso es ver quién es la
hipotenusa la hipotenusa es el lado que
es opuesto a este ángulo recto verdad
entonces ahora este de acá va a ser se
va entonces déjame poner por acá el
teorema de pitágoras otra vez dice que
dice que a cuadrada más b cuadrada es
igual a c cuadrada vale entonces lo que
sabemos es que a cuadrada más b cuadrada
es igual a 12 al cuadrado 12 al cuadrado
que 144 144 y ahora tenemos que decidir
quién está y quién es b pero aquí no
importa verdad este lado y este lado
juegan el mismo papel aquí y acá
entonces podemos decir que este era
y que éste era b entonces tendríamos que
6 al cuadrado o sea 36 más b al cuadrado
es igual a 144
de esta forma tenemos que ve al cuadrado
es igual a 144 menos 36 144 menos 33
unos 36 es 108 y ahora si podemos
obtener sacándole la raíz a 108-108
podríamos dejar la respuesta así pero
como ya vimos algunos ejercicios de
simplificar radicando entonces vamos a
aplicar este conocimiento aquí vale
entonces observemos observemos que
108-108 es igual a creo que 36 por 3 3
por 6 18 y vamos 13 por 3 9 10 si
entonces tenemos que ve es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de 36 por 3 o sea los
factores de como un cuadrado por algo
que ya no es cuadrado y entonces b b es
igual a 6
a raíz de tres muy bien entonces con
esto obtenemos la longitud del cateto
correspondiente a b vale bueno le voy a
dejar hasta aquí porque ya no tengo
tanto tiempo pero espero que estos
ejemplos te hayan servido y bueno en los
siguientes vídeos veremos una
demostración del teorema de pitágoras o
tal vez más y veremos más ejemplos en
los cuales podemos aplicar el teorema de
pitágoras para obtener algunos lados que
en desconocemos